j'ai fait un peu le con pendant 4-5 mois
et il a pu avoir cette rechute qui est
arrivé maintenant ça fait ça fait un
mois et demi mais une nuit ça s'est
déclenché j'ai toussé toute la nuit et
avec ce qui m'est arrivé je suis vite
monté dans un avion aller contrôler en
effet j'ai vu d'un seul coup que il y
avait un ganglion qui avait fixé là je
vais faire une troisième chimio et puis
ensuite on ira regarder ce qui s'est
passé et de toute façon je serai
toujours en contrôle et avec cette
immunothérapie que je lâcherai plus
maintenant je ferai pas deux fois la
même bêtise mais que je vais devoir
organiser et suivre je pense pendant
quelques années parce que ça fonctionne
plutôt pas mal mais il faut pas le
lâcher merci Isabelle saporteur d'être
avec nous éditrice de l'autobiographie
de Florent Pagny panie par Florent merci
d'être là ma chérie alors dans un
premier temps on a vu hier on a
énormément d'extrait à vous montrer
parce qu'il était hier soir sur France 2
comment il nous a parlé de son état de
santé donc là c'est vrai qu'il va il va
avoir recours encore à l'immunothérapie
comme il l'a dit
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles vous
écoutez moi là je le vois très
régulièrement Florent parce qu'on
travaille sur ce sur cet ouvrage
ensemble et c'est un homme qui est
solaire qui est plein de vie qui est
incroyable qui donne de l'énergie à tout
le monde moi je peux vous dire que en
fait quand on prépare les choses
ensemble il y a plutôt plutôt en train
de me taper dans le dos en me disant
mais écoute alors hein faut avoir le
moral pour se bouger faut y aller et
c'est il a une énergie communicative un
peu comme vous Cyril
c'est un bâton voilà ce qu'il écrit dans
son livre lorsqu'il parle de l'annonce
de sa maladie je ne suis pas encore mort
c'est donc que je suis méchamment vivant
je me remets debout prêt au combat
pourtant on sait donc Florent n'a pas
suivi le traitement qui lui était
conseillé afin de rentrer en Patagonie
peut-être que s'il avait suivi
aujourd'hui il serait plus sous
traitement devait suivre un traitement
immunothérapie c'est ce qu'il a
sous-entendu dans l'extrait qu'on vient
de voir
il regrette ça ou pas
écoutez je sais pas je suis pas
l’impression que ce soit quelqu'un qui
regrette grand chose en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui vit sa vie un petit peu
comme ça qui qui choisit de la mordre à
pleines dents qui s'est jeté dans le
cinéma puis après dans la chanson
c'est pas quelqu'un qui regarde en
arrière c'est pas quelqu'un qui regarde
dans le rétroviseur et regarde devant il
est plein de vie pense à l'avenir et
c'est des projets tous les jours et donc
non c'est lui qui a décidé de faire
cette autobiographie parce qu'elle va
sortir le 5 avril donc là elle sort le 5
avril exactement mercredi il a décidé de
décrire cet autobiographie alors il a
choisi de la faire il y a deux ans en
fait à un moment où il était pas du tout
question de la maladie justement il
parlait de ces 7 vie donc le cinéma
la chanson tout ça et sa famille sa
femme la Patagonie et il y a cette
huitième vie qui s'est greffée mais si
vous voulez en fait c'était plutôt un
livre qui racontait un petit peu tout
son parcours son parcours de
méritocratie parce que c'est quelqu'un
voilà qui a décidé de quitter sa
province à 15 ans de partir conquérir le
monde à Paris pour se faire il est quand
même voilà il est parti de rien il était
à l'Armée du Salut il s'est fait tout
seul c'est quelqu'un qui rien n'a été
donné qui a un parcours incroyable qui
s'est parfois planté qui s'est toujours
relevé que vous entendrez jamais se
plaindre c'est assez chouette je crois
il dit dans il va falloir me falloir il
va falloir me falloir recalculer tout
mon programme ou même l'oublier pour ne
plus avoir en tête qu'une seule chose
guérir tu es la tumeur sera mon seul
ordre du jour en un claquement de doigts
tout le reste est devenu secondaire
j'étais en train de surfer sur de vagues
idées de projets de vie future me
revoilà sur terre je ne suis plus un
chanteur je ne suis plus un rêveur je
suis un homme et qui plus est un homme
dont la santé est menacée je viens de me
prendre une claque dans la gueule je
suis malade et ce n'est pas une
métaphore je dois régler ce problème la
tournée annuler la date de sortie de ce
livre on verra après les différents
projets on en parle plus
on va retourner je vous montre
à l'époque
je sais pas ce que si vous écoute ce
soir il a très très envie de la faire
au moment où il a il a appris ça oui
bien sûr mais c'est vrai que c'est la
maladie bouleverse tout mais c'est
justement c'était l'autre jour il me
disait voilà tu vois ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que bon il fume plus sur
la sur la photo de couverture on le voit
en train de fumer et bien sûr et il me
dit bah écoute tu sais quoi ma ma voix
est encore plus belle qu'avant et je
peux vous dire que pour avoir eu la
chance de l'écouter chanter hier c'est
vrai qu'on était tous très émus
donc voilà je trouve que c'est vrai que
la couverture elle fait beaucoup parler
parce que on y voit Florent Pagny fumer
parce que on va en parler mais il en
parlait hier encore le cancer du poumon
plusieurs études ont démontré que 84 90%
des cas de concerts du poumon sont liés
au tabagisme et c'est d'ailleurs exprimé
sur le sujet hier chez Laurent
Delahousse et c'est vrai que regarder ce
qu'il dit sur la photo du livre c'est
vrai que bon elle peut avoir un côté un
petit peu
un peu agaçantes quelque part mais en
même temps ouais parce que on se
présente plus en fumant ouais c'est pas
agaçant mais bon ça peut provoquer des
choses des réactions mais en même temps
c'est vrai que je raconte que c'est
quelque chose quand on rentrait dans mon
intimité il y a un moment on voyait
toujours avec avec mon petit mégot au
bout de la bouche et donc bon ben voilà
c'est fini ça n'arrivera mieux c'est
terminé et puis bon ça a eu ses
conséquences aussi parce que bon c'est
vrai que c'est lié un petit peu à tout
ça quoi
il est incroyable moi j'adore enfin en
panique il est top vraiment
il a l'air toujours de bonne humeur il a
l'air non mais c'est vrai
comme tout le monde mais dans ces cas-là
vous êtes au courant c'est un peu c'est
un peu comme vous aussi donc
voilà mais moi j'aime bien je suis
pareil
c'est vrai qu'il y a bon en même temps
pardonnez-moi mais il le fait mis rien
c'est à dire qu'il dit voilà j'ai fumé
ça des répercussions sur ma santé je me
bats il faut suivre un protocole quand
on veut s'en sortir je trouve que voilà
c'est une belle leçon de vie oui dans le
livre il raconte que vous a dit un
moment ok on le fait mais c'est cette
photo en couverture je n'en veux pas
d'autres est-ce que vous ça vous a fait
hésiter est-ce que cette photo un moment
elle vous a paru un peu trop
provocatrice alors elle m'a pas fait
hésiter mais j'ai quand même essayé de
faire changer d'avis parce que pour vous
dire c'est quand même une tannée parce
que du coup on a une campagne de pub un
petit peu partout en France et donc on
peut pas montrer ce qui n'est pas une
cigarette en plus donc on ne peut pas le
montrer donc une cigarette on pourrait
pas et c'est encore moins donc il a
fallu faire une espèce de bandeau sur
sur la fiche pour cacher la fumée alors
moi au début j'avais essayé de d'effacer
juste
la cigarette donc disons et de laisser
juste la fumée les mecs de la régie
publicitaire ils m'ont demandé si je les
prenais pour des abrutis
parce que c'est la fumée ça pourrait
être la fumée n'importe quoi mais non ça
peut pas d'affirmer n'importe quoi mais
en tout cas il avait raison je pense
parce que c'est vrai que ça raconte
quelque chose
dans le livre il y a un extrait très
très fort notamment
quand il était sur le tournage de The
Voice en ce qu'il a appris que son
concert était inopérable seul dans ma
loge reçoit du percute je ne prends pas
le temps donc que l'encaisser je
raccroche 10 secondes plus tard je
pousse la porte de la loge et me dirige
vers le plateau ce sentiment de devoir
faire comme si tout allait bien en
sachant que mon pronostic vital est
inscrit sur un bout de papier c'est
horrible ça c'est un moment
c'est un professionnel je pense que
chacun d'entre vous ici sur le plateau
vous feriez pareil c'est-à-dire que
c'est quand même des métiers qui sont
pas faciles ce que vous faites aussi ces
métiers de représentation donc c'est
vrai que voilà vous êtes là pour faire
passer quelque chose et au moment où
vous faites passer quelque chose vous
vous oubliez un peu vous-même donc c'est
vrai que c'est des métiers qui sont
difficiles on se rend pas compte de ça
alors dans son autobiographie uniquement
de son cancer puisqu'il a d’ailleurs il
a décidé d'écrire comme vous l'avez dit
avant tout ça il revient sur toutes les
grandes étapes de c'est histoire d'amour
ces problèmes d'argent et notamment ses
problèmes avec le fils il a pas hésité à
prendre la parole sur le sujet il s'est
expliqué hier soir dessus regardez très
longtemps j'entendais toujours la
réflexion à payer tes impôts mais bon au
bout d'un moment on a fini quand même
j'ai réussi quand même à expliquer
clairement comment ça se passait et que
l'artiste français paye ses impôts en
France puisque les performances elles
sont en France et moi je suis
franco-français donc je vais pas
m'exporter et ma musique elle a lieu que
là mes programmes télé The Voice c'est
en France donc j'ai toujours payé mes
impôts ici
alors oui alors ça il en parle beaucoup
quand même c'est un traumatisme pour lui
c'est à dire tout ça revient sous tout
au long du livre il en parle avec Pascal
à l'époque et comment ça s'est
passé
pour lui ça reste quand même quelque
chose de marquant oui parce que je pense
que il l'a vécu ça vraiment comme une
injustice en fait et puis c'est quelque
chose qui s'est traîné très très
longtemps et des questions qui étaient
récurrentes donc c'est pour ça qu'il
avait envie de l'évacuer une bonne fois
pour tout dans ce livre et je trouve que
c'est bien parce qu'en fait ça tourne
cette page et qu'au fond les gens n'y
comprenaient rien moi la première en
fait pour vous dire quand il m'a il m'a
donné son son son ouvrage je m'en fait
je me suis en fait on comprend enfin ce
qui s'est passé on peut tourner la page
je vais passer à autre chose parce que
c'est vrai qu'il traînait toujours ce
truc un peu sulfureux
il y a eu un changement drastique dans
sa communication à Florent Pagny sert
qu'au début il a annoncé son concert
dans une vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux
qui était assez la conique on l'a pas
beaucoup vu la il se met à faire
beaucoup de plateau télé et dit dans le
livre qui regrette d'avoir annoncé son
concert de cette manière sur les réseaux
sociaux
mais en tout cas il a été très surpris
de la façon dont ça a été à ce point là
repris alors quand on en discute
ensemble il me dit en fait c'est pas mon
moyen de communication ça Instagram tout
ça et
il dit dans le livre j'ai suivi là
encore mon instinct ainsi qu'à certains
sons pratiques en rendant public ce qui
m'arrivait j'ai pensé que le moyen le
plus direct d'expliquer aux personnes
qui avaient acheté leur billet pour les
40 concerts restants que je ne pouvais
pas honorer mes dates étaient de leur
dire franchement les choses j'ai choisi
un sta le seul réseau social que j'ai
sur mon portable pour communiquer et
puis en fait
non c'est ça
et aussi dit la libération de la parole
même des amis proches trois amis proches
m'ont révélé que le cancer qu'ils
avaient jusqu'à leur garder pour eux
ayant choisi de régler leurs trucs dans
leur coin je suis tombé des NU s'ils en
avaient parlé nous aurions pu les
entourer des médecins des malades m'ont
dit c'est fait un bien fou on se sent
moins seul j'aurais dû me rendre compte
à quel point cette maladie pourtant
présente fréquente et toujours tabou
voilà et il dit l'annonce entier je vais
revenir sur scène j'aime trop ça
finalement
il va retourner sur scène et c'est vrai
qu'il y a il a sa voix qui est
merveilleuse et ça va être le 30 juin
aux Arènes de Nîmes
sur sur mon TiAl en fait vous mettrez
vos chroniques
donne du mot aux autres
[Rires]
vivre comme ça sous les feux de la rampe
et d'ailleurs je pense que c'est pas un
hasard si pour sa grande histoire
d'amour celle avec sa femme de toujours
avec Asus Sénat en fait il est en
Patagonie et il est dans un dans un
endroit j'ai discutais avec Kenji Girac
hier je suis restée 5 jours c'était
génial c'est magnifique mais il y a pas
de Wi-Fi il y a pas et je pense que je
la choisis un endroit où il y a pas de
wifi on capte pas et on est tranquille
et on est tous les deux en gros pour ça
aussi en fait avec sa famille avec sa
tribu parce que c'est quelqu'un très
authentique qui a ses amis depuis
toujours voilà je crois très fidèle oui
il y a des très belles anecdotes
effectivement sur ces sur ces femmes et
avec ça sa femme actuelle il raconte que
quand il s'en rencontrer déjà elle ne
voulait même pas lui dire bonjour il
tente de lui serrer la main elle le
basse complètement etc et elle était
avec quelqu'un nommé ou surnommée
Geronimo en mannequin et donc il va tout
faire pour que cette relation s'arrête
et conquérir sa femme actuelle hyper
beau comme euh c'est très très beau et
puis là pour le coup moi je suis sûr que
ça
t'a fait sourire aussi Géraldine c'est
qu'il raconte aussi sa première nuit
c'est sa première nuit d'amour avec
Assou Sénat en disant je l'ai emmené
voir le concert de Bono cette femme je
fantasmais sur elle depuis des mois et
des mois et la première nuit d'amour il
ne se passe rien parce qu'il est
tellement ému que il ne peut rien se
passer
[Rires]
avec ce qui lui arrive ça sauf que c'est
un débat intéressant aussi à soumettre
toute façon c'est quelqu'un qui pense
vous le connaissez pas du tout
avant et je j'ai fait sa connaissance
quand j'ai repris la direction de la
maison Fayard et parce que je voulais
absolument qu'il reste chez nous pour
pour tout vous dire et il m'a dit mais
toi je sais pas qui tu es je sais pas ce
que tu as dans le ventre et je me suis
battu comme une tigresse pour que ce
livre soit publié chez nous je suis très
très fière qu'il soit publié exactement
et alors c'est vrai qu'il y a énormément
de révélations dedans et on a pu voir
hier Florent Pagny chanter on l'avait eu
enfin je voulais vous parler de sa voix
où il nous a dit qu'il avait une voix
pour lui encore magnifique plus belle
qu'avant parce que il y a plus de
cigarettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
reviennent et que tous mes merveilles
pour que l'envie me revienne et que tous
mes merveilles
[Musique]
choisi par Florent
c'est Fayard oui c'est super beau et par
rapport à la voix il raconte que dans
toute sa carrière il refusait de faire
deux concerts de suite par exemple
toujours un concert tous les deux jours
pour préserver sa voix même quand il
était produit par Gérard Louvin qui est
producteur insistait lui refusait non le
livre est super intéressant vraiment
plein de choses ça fait 500 pages quand
même
pour moi qui n'aimaient pas lire il a
fallu que je le lise le relise le relise
sur sa huitième vie justement parce
qu'il disait cette vie mais finalement
elle entame la 8e B c'est formidable